I am a geek not a nerd not a dork I'm
not a dweeb nerds our scholastic
overachievers dorks are perpetually
awkward in social situations and dweebs
well I think do weaves were hunted to
extinction in the 1980s but I am a geek
and proud of it there are more of us out
there than you might think a geek is
someone with a passion for something
beyond a mere interest or hobby they're
the big ones Star Trek geek the video
game geek the comic book geek but it can
be almost anything knowing why she Hulk
can change her form at will while
regular Hulk Kent might not matter to
you but it matters to us
most people who get out about things
want to live them horror movie geeks
like to make their bloody home movies a
truly dedicated fantasy geek Mike Wright
a few Harry Potter fan fics
and somebody who is a dungeon master who
spends all of their free time detailing
a Dungeons and Dragons campaign drawing
maps writing ancient texts and
accounting for every possible outcome
well that person might be a serial
killer my point is we care about these
things to a level that you may think
unhealthy but look around is it really
so different from the sports fan the car
not the reality TV junkie of course they
never own up to being geeks but this
isn't about them this is about those of
us that wear the label with pride you
think you know what we're like you think
you can spot us
you think we wear Star Wars t-shirts
talk through our noses and stay up late
on the internet chatting about how
spider-man three was the worst movie
ever you're wrong we blend in we live
among you and you don't even know it we
bag your groceries we do your taxes we
teach your children we are geeks and we
are everywhere